é difícil mesmo nesses tempos é onde é
somente para que o trabalho
o hip hop os movimentos negros você vê
um pouco os negros ocupando a papéis é
essa luta cotidiana os 400 anos de
escravidão que a gente teve no brasil e
que não foram ainda passados a limpo e
esse desequilíbrio então a gente vai
cantando e transformando em poesia pra
não se arrebentar assim como fizeram os
meninos que dançaram no hip hop cantar e
pegar o microfone o que fazer com essa
energia com essa raiva com esse
enfrentamento diário há quem consiga
transformar em poesia a can transform
outras coisas mas são todas as maneiras
legítimas de viver na terra então
falando sobre isso eu vou fazer mais um
problema que se chama de as pôr a
louvando a todos os ancestrais ea todas
as pessoas que deram a vida porque a
gente tá aqui podendo ouvir o que quer
podendo falar o que quer e poder fazer o
que quer porque muita gente deu a vida
para que a gente pudesse estar aqui
agora abrem se as portas ea diáspora se
levanta espanta
adoro medo há dúvidas e inseguranças
desconfianças complexos de inferioridade
inconsciência esquecimento não dá mais
pra disfarçar a hora é agora chegou o
momento identidade com a sua quem é você
e seus pais e os pais de seus pais com a
origem da sua cultura
de onde vieram seus ancestrais pois
respeitar quem veio antes ensinar que
vem depois ativar a história viva a
memória saber quem é quem da novell bus
luiza marfim patrick lumumba amílcar
cabral solano trindade mestre nenel mal
com ex e james brown se um bico joão
cândido bairro ipê newton john martin
luther king pastor na vida e na morte e
guerreiro da marcha da libertação e de
todos os mártires da paz perseguida
abolicionista os guerrilheiros lutadores
guerreiros quilombolas e todos que
lutaram e
era uma vida para que pudéssemos estar
aqui agora neste momento entramos em
cena pedimos a todos a participar no
passado nos foi concedida a permissão
para começar o chá lá meu pai em pena de
nós tenha dó à volta do mundo a grande
seus poder bem maior porque o santos
aprendeu canto me visto de fé de amor e
de paz veja uma estrela se aproximando
toda a grandeza dos orishas o brilho da
lua do ferro do fogo da terra da lama do
vento e numa peça licença e vou chegando
impunidade ou quer cantar poder para o
povo preto